[Musique]
pourquoi le temps c'est pas le même je
te parle pas d'un métier où je te parle
de deux heures interminables que tu vas
passer avec la crème des cassos de son
lycée
[Musique]
aucune caméra
t'es pas un loser tu y vas tu lui parles
elle a sorti tous les chocs et tu viens
souvent encore louis tous les habits
j'adore mais rien à faire dans ma vie
ah ouais d'accord t'as un peu de béton
en fait de ça ok c'est une blague
les deux ensembles à fermer l'oeil je
vous sais pas
il ya quelque chose de bizarre merci
c'est quoi tout ce que je vis j'ai déjà
vécu
oui les parents forment la paire mais là
je vous sais pas et chaque fois que je
mets langdell puis trois minutes
je reviens systématiquement au début de
la cote 1 92 et du coup bah je suis
bloqué ça c'est marrant ça ouais c'est
vrai c'est pas très bon
il est collé avis est investi la salle
sont toutes pourries
on dit pourrit pas pourri que les salles
sont pour its qu'on accorde le sujet
avec sa mère toutes les communautés p 10
[Musique]
il faut que je trouve une fin à cette
histoire très bonne idée du temps là
souvent non mais là j'ai rien là c'est
exactement ce que je craignais
[Applaudissements]
non qu'ils échouent pour 3 minutes
d'ottawa total de tuffé marque al oula
charles tagen sécu est le patron
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourri si les pizzas oui c'est
pour moi
[Musique]
tiens mon cas
quand tu y crois c'est un bon endroit